ايام ساخنه تعيشها مدينه شيبكينا تعد
الاعنف خلال فتره الصراع ما دفع سلطات
الاقليم لانشاء مراكز مؤقته لاواء سكان
المناطق الحدوديه داخل مدينه بلغراد
عمليه القصف كانت باسلحه مخيفه تركنا كل
شيء واخذنا ما استطعنا حمله سريعا والده
اضطرت لترك القطه والكلب والنباتات وهربت
نحن ايضا رحلنا هذا المكان هو صله رياضيه
للكره الطائره تم تعديلها واعاده تنسيقها
سريعا لاستقبال اللاجئين
الناس هنا اصبحوا يدركون ما حدث بسبب
وضعهم النفسي وبدات تظهر اعراض الوضع من
ارتفاع للضغط او تغير في مستويات السكر
الكثير من الناس تم اجلائهم سريعا لذلك لم
يتمكنوا من جمع اشيائهم ولذلك نحن نقوم
بمساعدتهم الارقام هنا تتجاوز حاجز الالف
ومن المقرر استيعاب 250 اخرين عودتهم الى
منازلهم ورهنهم باستقرار الوضع في المنطقه
لكن وحصبر روايه السلطات الوضع في الاقليم
يزداد سوءا عبد الجواد الروش لقناتي
العربيه والحدث
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات